on continue notre série de podcasts en
préparation de la draft NBA 2023 vous
êtes bien sûr envergure et dans ces
petits portraits on vous donne
l'essentiel sur les candidats les plus
importants à nos yeux de cette draft les
prospects les plus importants
cet épisode ce sera l'essentiel sur
challenge
S comme vous l'appellerez bientôt né le
19 juin 2003 en mètre 96 98 kg de mètres
8 d'envergure plutôt un garde on la
numéro 8 sur notre dernier big board
chez envergure donc plus haut que la
moyenne largement plus haut et aspire ne
voit 14e meilleur joueur de cette draft
zathletique 16e de Ringer 22e pour en
parler Mathias et Thomas salut les gars
salut
à tous
Mathias c'est toi le spécialiste de la
conférence big time chez nous chez
envergure c'est là où il jouait Jalène
Gucci fino du côté d'Indiana chez les
hoosers mais d'abord on commence par sa
biographie comment il en est arrivé là
ce qu'il a des parents connus où est-ce
qu'il a grandi tout ça tout ça tu vas
nous raconter tout ça alors
du coup lui c'est un gars qui grandit un
Pittsburg
je connais pas vraiment j'ai pas vu de
choses passées sur ses parents en tout
cas
je te ce côté là donc c'est un joueur
qui était au lycée à la très réputée
monte vers l'Académie
au côté de d'Harry couette par exemple
et lycée dans lequel il va gagner
en 2021 à 2022 coup sûr cool le gecko
national donc il y a un peu le Graal de
du trophée en High School
et ensuite
[Musique]
commencer à commettre à Pittsburg dans
un dans sa ville natal avant de se
rétracter et de choisir donc Indiana
plus tard
après le High School j'ai vu que il
avait fait beaucoup de workout avec des
joueurs pro il y en a même fait avec
Paul George entre autres
donc voilà et donc après ça il arrive à
Indiana
[Musique]
pour pour son universitaire il arrivait
Indiana comme une grosse grosse recrue
comme grosse recrue 5 étoiles top 25
c'est ça
classe d'âge je vois que sur sa fiche
Wikipédia j'aimerais qu'il a des cousins
des grands cousins qui ont joué
en universitaire voilà
quand cousine que je skateboard et un
grand cousin qui a joué au collège
football
avait-il au sein de cette équipe
d'Indiana Thomas qu'est-ce qu'on lui
demandait cette année à Janelle Gucci
fino qui soit offensivement surtout mais
aussi défensivement
alors donc déjà
donc il faut souligner que le deuxième
gros Guard de cette équipe Xavier
Johnson c'est de laisser cette année il
a dû jouer une petite dizaine de matchs
c'est un genre vraiment important
l'année dernière donc je finis endosser
un très gros rôle des cette année dans
cette équipe il faut bien sûr souligner
qui joue avec 13 et Jackson Davis un des
tous meilleurs joueurs du pays voir le
meilleur jour du pays cette année qui a
fait une année tout simplement
monstrueux
dominant au poste exactement donc
meneur il avait pour pour but de servir
beaucoup son intérieur qui était
monstrueux à l'intérieur il recevait
beaucoup de ballons au poste c'était là
tout principal de scoring de très
Jackson Davis mais pouvait aussi jouer
un peu de pick and roll de temps en
temps c'est nous chez fino sur son
scoring c'est un genre qui évolue
beaucoup à mi distance 52% de ses tiers
sont des jumper à mi distance qu'il aime
beaucoup la zone au niveau de la ligne
des lances et prendre notamment le côté
droit pour envoyer cette il a une bonne
réussite sur cette jumper à deux points
il a 42%, c'est plutôt propre par contre
au global il a un scoring assez peu
efficace vu qu'il est assez peu efficace
au Cercle seulement 53% et il a 33% à 3
points sur un volume relativement faible
il doit en prendre trois tentatives à
faire match ce qui fait qu'il a
seulement un effectif philo personne de
46 donc ce qui est classe dans le dans
les 20% les moins efficaces de Division
1 comme je l'ai dit bah assez peu au
Cercle seulement 20% de s'étire et les
cas avant de frites rate et là du coup
il avait un gros usage de 25% 30% pour
13,5 c'était vraiment le duo for de
cette équipe et à côté on avait plus des
joueurs de profil dédiés donc challenge
chez nous pouvait beaucoup porter la
balle dans cette équipe et en tant que
défenseur et défense et défendez pardon
les guarda adverse ça pouvait être du
gros joueur vu que c'est un pont
défenseur on va pouvoir en reparler et
pouvez défendre plusieurs profils avec
son physique très très tanqué fait 1m96
98 kg donc il faut défendre plusieurs
types de joueurs cette année Mathias toi
qui était spécialiste big time cette
année ça s'ajoute beaucoup en transition
c'est plus du demi-terreur Indiana quand
même
[Musique]
quelle va être leur argument numéro un
quel est son son style d'appel
je sais pas si il a vraiment un skill
d'appel en particulier parce que c'est
pas un joueur pour moi qui vraiment
spécialiste dans un domaine si ce n'est
peut-être le migraine je mais c'est pas
vraiment un ticket d'entrer dans le
billet c'est je pense que c'est surtout
un joueur qui sait tout faire qui qui
mesure 1 m 98 sur un poste de garde donc
c'est la taille idéale pour son poste en
NBA
qui s'est shootait qui s'est créé son
shoot qui s'est défendent très bien
aussi donc
potentiellement un joueur qui a pas
vraiment de gros gros défaut mais
surtout des qualités à peaufiner donc
voilà pourquoi pour moi il peut vraiment
jouer un billet et intéressantes
Thomas qu'est-ce que tu en penses est-ce
que toi tu as une raison particulière
pour laquelle tu braves
pour moi la principale raison pour le
drafté c'est que c'est un des meilleurs
joueurs de piano rôle de la cuvée c'est
un des meilleurs passeurs de la cuvée il
avait une belle relation avec 13 Jackson
Davis il aime beaucoup la pocket passe
notamment très Jackson Davis peut
commencer c'est son rôle très loin du
cercle donc beaucoup de Pocket pas
c'était utilisé il a un très formidra
range c'est vraiment son atout principal
au scoring je l'ai dit au niveau
contextuel 52% de ses tirs sont des
jumper à deux points donc il aime
énormément cette zone notamment du côté
droit il est vraiment très fluide sur
son lâcher sur sa mécanique ça lui
permet vraiment bien sanctionner dans
cette zone ensuite le scoring peut être
un peu plus compliqué comme on l'a dit
mais c'est un très bon passeur très bon
joueur demi de range c'est vraiment un
joueur qui rend ses coéquipier meilleur
il a il a un bon dribble il sait gérer
le tempo il s'est joué lentement il
s'est joué plus rapidement et donc ça
lui permet d'être un des tous meilleurs
joueurs de pick and roll de cette UV et
dans le top 3 assurément donc pour moi
ça peut être un meneur qui peut porter
la balle en une c'est pour
potentiellement lui donner la balle dans
certaines situations clairement oui
capable de lâcher les petites passes
avec de la variété pendant le dribble
main droite main gauche demain etc ce
qui est intéressant il est grand pour
son poste tu le disais Mathias très
justement est-ce que tu peux me parler
de sa défense quel comment tu trouves ça
latéralité
sa concentration son moteur aussi son
intensité
moi pour moi ça défense c'est un vrai
vrai point fort chez lui parce que il
peut vraiment défendre
il est pas embêté à défendre des des
joueurs très petits qu'on peut voir
souvent NCA mais il s'est aussi défendre
des plus grands c'est un joueur qui
bouge très très bien et qui souvent
utilisé sur sur le PEA le point of
attack comme on dit maintenant donc ce
côté là il y a pour moi je vois pas
vraiment de gros soucis c'est un très
bon défenseur
et alors quel qu'est-ce qui peut
débloquer vraiment son potentiel à Janet
ou chifino pour pour toi qu'est-ce que
quelle est la clé pour que vraiment il
est un niveau dans trois ou quatre ans
qui soit digne d'un top 10 Top 14 comme
je sais pas combien tu l'as toi sur ton
big board autour de 15 quelque chose
pour pour valoir un top 20 draft quoi ok
qu'est-ce qui doit développer pour toi
pour
m'arriver à ce niveau là je pense qu'il
doit être plus efficace sur son shoot
puisque c'est un joueur qui qui mise
beaucoup sur son sur son pull-up game
mais qui est pas toujours très très
efficace et d'ailleurs derrière la ligne
cette année il est il est 43% je crois
de tête
en question même si il est létal sur
midrange mais il se pose des questions
de derrière la ligne et au Cercle un peu
comme tout se poser un peu l'année
dernière sur un Johnny Davis par exemple
donc
l'historique Johnny Davis te fait un peu
peur ouais ouais non mais il y a
plusieurs prospects comme ça souvent qui
qui sont qui sont
sur lesquels on se pose des questions
sur leur shoot extérieur et on voit qu'à
chaque fois quand NBA c'est ça pardonne
ça pardonne pas il faut vraiment avoir
un tire fiable mais je pense que lui là
est vraiment s'il doit améliorer quelque
chose c'est c'est ça c'est son shoot
c'est son pull-up game pas beaucoup de
lancer Franco comme elle disait cette
année 70
7,6% de réussite sur ces lancers francs
tenter ce qui est pas mal mais pas non
plus digne d'un shooter létal est-ce que
Thomas tu tu vois des des points de
progression au-delà du du tir qui
peuvent l'amener à justement vraiment
développer ce potentiel qu'il a
moi pour moi ce qui va être important et
que j'allais nucifino c'est développer
développer pardon songe of bol vu que
c'est principalement un joueur qui a
besoin de la balle pour l'instant pour
exister comme on l'a dit
range et en fait le problème c'est si il
se monte pas plus efficace au cercle et
à trois points ça va rester un score
trop peu efficace et donc si on a un
score trop peu efficace on NBA on a beau
être un très bon passeur un bon
défenseur on va pas forcément avoir
toujours la balle en main parce qu'il y
aura plus force pas pour nous donner la
balle et donc il doit vu qu'il a la
taille pour jouer 1 2 voir limite 3 il
doit développer un qui va pouvoir
retrouver des minutes sur diverses
positions donc ça c'est très intéressant
il peut défendre pas mal de types de
joueurs comme on l'a dit il va pouvoir
faciliter le jeu et va pouvoir passer
mes doigts plus être plus les tables sur
catchan shoot même à trois points les
meilleures surpooloc que sur quatre
chances pour moi c'est un vrai bon
shooter en rythme c'est pour ça qu'il
est très bon sur peau la famille
distance mais quand ses pieds sont quand
les pieds sont déjà un peu plus dans le
ciment ça peut être plus compliqué pour
lui donc pour moi il doit vraiment
améliorer sa faculté à jouer au football
plus space le terrain améliorer son cas
de chaîne shoot pour pouvoir s'il
devient pas assez fort en tant que
scorer un ball pouvoir être plus
efficace à voler
une sortie de secours s'il arrive pas à
devenir élite balance en fait ma pièce
tu penses qu'il aura le ballon
qui tu l'as tu l'imagines comment en
fait quel comment tu l'imagines et
en dérivé quel serait ça sa situation
idéale tu peux me parler de certaines
franchises ou pas ou simplement de d'un
rôle qu'on lui donnerait qui pour toi
lui permettrait de se développer
correctement
justement moi je suis je suis vraiment
curieux de voir comment il va être
utilisé parce que pour moi ça doit être
un joueur sur qui on donne le ballon
[Musique]
peut-être gérer un second audit dans un
premier temps dans une première année
avec dans un environnement idéal un bon
mentor pour pour l'aider mais vraiment
avoir le ballon faire jouer ses
partenaires mais c'est pas dit que qu'on
lui demande de faire ça moi j'ai un peu
peur qu'on l'utilise parce que c'est
vrai que c'est un joueur qui a une image
assez forte de shooter de shotmaker
donc j'ai un peu peur qu'on l'utilise
comme un comme un joueur de sortie de
banque qui va marquer des points plutôt
que de l'utiliser comme un comme un vrai
playmaker en post mal quoi
oui ce qu'il est mais
il faut être vraiment élite pour avoir
le ballon MBA donc pas forcément évident
Thomas qu'est-ce que tu peux me dire sur
la mentalité que tu as vu que ce soit
sur le terrain ou en dehors pour pour JS
moi j'aime bien qu'on l'a dit c'est
l'école Mondevert donc il a joué en ICEO
la menthe verte à Kevin Boyle comme
coach et quand je Kevin bol déjà on se
doit de défendre donc c'est un joueur
qui défend tout le temps qui est
toujours actif qui est moins actif c'est
un genre discipliné c'est un soldat
c'est un col bleu c'est un mec qui
encourage chez partenaire c'est un très
bon passeur comme on l'a dit c'est un
pasteur gag donc c'est un mec qui va
essayer de mettre en avant ses
partenaires c'est un mec qui va toujours
défendre qui va faire les efforts donc
moi j'ai aucun souci sur sur le
comportement je trouve qu'il a une bonne
mentalité de mentalité de travailleurs
mentalité joueur collectif qui qui joue
pour l'équipe et qui pense pas à
l'individuel avant Mathias j'ai une
question pour toi il y a quelque chose
qui m'intrigue je vois un gabarit très
très solide et pourtant je vois 53,9% de
réussite au Cercle ce qui est quand même
pas ouf du tout comment comment on
explique ça ce qu'il avait des shoot
particulièrement difficiles est-ce que
il a des problèmes de
unilatéralité c'est à dire
il finit surtout d'une seule main que il
gère mal le contact pourquoi il se
pourcentage est si faible
déjà c'est un joueur qui va rarement au
Cercle c'est vrai donc
forcément c'est c'est compliqué c'est un
joueur aussi qui a pas forcément de
grosse qualitatletic c'est pas un joueur
hyper explosif qui va qui va facilement
monter très vite au cercle et voilà il a
pas non plus deux bonnes mains il est
surtout main droite
et donc voilà c'est pas c'est pas son
domaine de prédilection il a pas un
physique pour vraiment finir fort au
cercle mais il va devoir progresser sur
sur cet aspect là c'est sûr
est-ce que vous avez des des
comparaisons pour j'allais notre shifino
et est-ce que vous y croyez ces deux
questions en une des comptes ça peut
être des comparaisons juste de rôles ou
de trajectoire de joueurs qui sont un
peu similaires en sortant de fac et qui
ensuite se développe en NBA en bien ou
en mal Thomas
est-ce que je ne comparaison pas
forcément est-ce que j'y crois ouais j'y
crois peut-être pas aussi que d'autres
de mes camarades je suis en verre dur
mais je pense qu'en fin de loterie ou
jusqu'à 20 et quelques potentiellement
je pense que ça peut être un joueur
intéressant il a il a pas mal de choses
pour lui il a la taille qui va le
permettre de jouer à plusieurs positions
il a la défense c'est un joueur
intelligent il s'est dribbler il sait
très bien passé la shote à mi distance
il continue de bien se développer
derrière l'art il va pas avoir forcément
énormément besoin de devenir un monstre
certes il arrive déjà beaucoup plus
space le terrain ça va pouvoir lui
permettre de jouer à football donc ça va
être peut-être le style principal pour
lui a développé j'aime bien sa mentalité
comme je l'ai dit il a un bon cuit
basket c'est un joueur attentif il
écoute bien son coach on ne va pas
parler tout à l'heure parmi était dans
la mentalité mais il était bien à
l'écoute à l'écoute pardon de son coach
cette année Indiana donc c'est
intéressant je pense que c'est un joueur
qui a vraiment des bonnes facultés pour
réussir j'ai quelques doutes sur ces
skills c'est pour ça que je prends pas
aussi que j'aurais pu penser à un moment
de la saison un petit peu déçu sur la
deuxième partie mais je trouve que c'est
intéressant c'est un choix que des
atouts pour réussir donc comme l'a dit
comme l'a dit Mathias je pense que drive
une seconde unite en début de carrière
ça pourrait être très intéressant pour
lui pour continuer d'avoir la balle en
main car c'est là où il est plus
intéressant continue de développer son
tir et oui je pense qu'ils peuvent faire
une carrière NBA maintenant j'ai j'ai
quelques doutes forcément quelques
doutes sur le sur le show sur le jumper
notamment à trois points car même en
High School il tirait très très mal à
trois points cette année 33% c'est même
très bien pour lui par rapport à ce qui
se jeté à monde verbes donc hâte de voir
comment le shoot va se développer il a
une belle mécanique donc ça peut être
positif donc à suivre Mathias on y croit
et c'est peut-être des comparaisons je
prends
je suis pas je suis pas expert en
comparaison
qui va en NCA il a été très inconstant
il a vraiment alterné bon et moins bon
donc je pense qu'il va devoir essayer de
trouver une vraie régularité être être
plus efficace quand on l'a dit sur son
shoot mais moi j'y crois j'y crois avec
un bon environnement si on lui fait
confiance il va bien se développer
et si il faut vraiment une comparaison
peut-être peut-être du mal comme brocdon
dans l'idéal dans le vrai idéal
qui avait attendu un peu avant de
rejoindre la NBA et qui donc avait été
choisi au second tour mais qui avait du
coup été choisi
était élu Rouky up de hier pardon Janet
ou chifino qui était freshman de l'année
dans sa conférence dans la conférence
big time
pas de bêtises c'est ça c'était
l'essentiel sur lui sur Janet noche fino
joueur d'Indiana
vous avez sa fiche sur
envergure.co vous avez les autres
podcasts sur toutes les plateformes
concernant les autres joueurs et notre
série de podcasts sur Victor one byama
n'hésitez pas à aller cliquer et écouter
d'autres de ces podcasts pour vous
préparer à la draft NBA 2023 Ciao